yeah this stock is about the K of
correlation in spin systems and how is
it related to to the approximate
counting algorithms so let's begin with
this is important the example the hard
core model on the route 80 regulatory
truncated at level l with this boundary
condition fixing the leaves to be
occupied or unoccupied by the random
independent set which is sampled
proportional to this weight and in
physics a well-known critical phenomenon
is that this correlation between the
between this boundary condition and the
marginal distribution at the root the
case 20 as the depths girls to infinity
as long as this parameter is bounded by
this critical threshold called the
uniqueness threshold and if the
parameter lambda is above this threshold
and then there's always long-range
correlation and an amazing connection to
the computer science is an amazing
connection to the computer science is
this physical phase transition
phenomenon in the infinite regular
structure actually coincides with the
transition of the computational
complexity for approximate counting on
the graphs on the finite graphs of
pundai the maximum degrees and this talk
is about this beautiful connection from
the algorithm side and in spin systems
where the hacker motto is a special case
so this is a spin system given that
undirected undirected graph and fix the
integer Q a configuration design one of
the Q spin states
to every vertex and the weight of a
configuration is given by this product
of edge contributions and vertex
contributions described by this
interaction matrix which is actually a
symmetric binary constraint function and
also this unary constraint function both
with non-negative values so the
computational problem here is to compute
this partition function as well as to
sample from the skips distribution and
when Q exists equals to the steam the
spin states are pulling up to the
normalization the system the model can
be described fully by these three
parameters beta gamma for the edge
activity and lambda for the external
field okay and in particular when beta
equals zero chemicals one every
configuration with nonzero weight
corresponds to an independent set in the
graph with zero indicating a vertex
being occupied by the by the independent
set so this is the hakko model and when
beta cos gamma it is the easy modem and
when for for general cue the market spin
model when the interaction matrix is
like this it is the parts model
independence it means no edges I mean
they're a set of vertices that none of
them on every pair of the vertices as
it's not a decent
so okay so when beta equals zero this is
the proper q coloring of graph okay so
these are our models and I also want to
consider the monomyth dimer model of
four matchings which is not a spin
system but also a quite important model
and together with the hacker model these
two can be unified into a general
framework called a hyper graph matching
and together they are just a very
natural subclass of Holland problems and
if you're not for me familiar with
Holland framework it's okay just
remember that for these models the
marginal probabilities in any instance
any graphs is actually our marginal
probability in a tree of selfing works
so this this gives us some hope that the
correlation decay on trees might somehow
capture the checked ability of a person
accounting and you might have some
doubts on this because we know for third
ferromagnetic eating model the model is
a proximal despite there's no decay of
correlation I will explain later in this
talk maybe there can be some okay so the
marginal probability is play a key role
in the approximate county by the chain
rule this partition function completely
composed as a product of marginal
probabilities and if say if we can
approximately compute this marginal
probability with arbitrary condition
within an additive arrow efficiently
then we have a F Peters for the
partition function so from now we just
focus on the approximation of marginal
probabilities
okay and this approximation can be done
either by sampling from this conditional
Gibbs measure or by determining
determine astray by by correlation decay
algorithms the decay of correlation also
known as the spatial mixing is defined
like this the week special mixing
requires that in Gibbs measure the
correlation between between this
boundary condition and the gift keeps
distribution at a vertex measured by
this total variation distance the case
as the distance between the boundary and
vertex grow and the decay rate is given
by this decaying function Delta of the
distance and a week special mixing a
special mixing is defined for either
infinite graph or a family of infinitely
many finite graphs and on infinite graph
the week special mixing is equivalent to
the uniqueness of the infinite volume
Gibbs measures this is a generic
equivalents and in particular for the
hard core model this threshold is
actually the threshold for the
uniqueness of Gibbs measures on infinity
plus one regular tree and hence it is
called this condition is called a
uniqueness condition just assume
something a delta
sorry yes what assumptions are Delta do
you need it's serve banishing it's the
king but it in DK really slowly right
right it's okay as long as you know for
every submit must be must decay
exponentially but for the uniqueness
it's it's okay to be to decay slowly
yeah anyway that's the week special
mixing and the strong spatial mixing
require further that the correlation the
decay of correlation still holds even
conditioning on this a subset of
vertices being arbitrary fixed whose
States being up arbitrarily fixed so
with strong spatial mixing the marginal
probability this marginal probability
with an arbitrary condition is well
approximated by local information and
and to to establish the strong spatial
mixing as well as to to approximate this
value with not just the local
information but also local computation
this is done by a recursion and still
consider the hard core model and suppose
your graph is a tree and the marginal
probability of the root being occupied
by the random independent set can be
computed by this recursion of the
marginal probability of the children's
in the respective subtrees routed by
these children and this recursion is
easy to obtain and for some reason
usually we usually work on the another
recursion for the ratio of the marginal
probability being of being occupied and
unoccupied the ratio is just a function
of probability so it's easy to transform
from this recursion to this one or the
other way are wrong so this is the tree
recursion and if you
your graph is not a tree we can still
have this similar recursion but now we
have to create four different branch we
have to create a new instance and with
with subset of vertices whose States
being fixed according to the chain rule
and so this product is now is a
telescopic product and the recursion for
the graph marginal still has the same
form as the tree recursion and this is
true even additionally we conditioning
on a subset of vertices being officially
fixed and we can run this recursion to
the end and this it's finite it will
give us this self avoiding work tree
which is a tree that enumerates all the
self loading works from the vertex V and
the recursion what the graph marginals
is the same as the same as the the
recursion the tree recursion in this in
this cell phone work tree so the
marginal at vertex in a graph is
preserved by the marginal at the root in
this cell for democracy expanded from
networking and and it is easy to see
that if we have strong spatial mixing in
trees then we have a strong spatial
mixing in graphs and also because the
self wouldn't work tree is also a device
for the for the computation of this this
marginal probability if we have strong
spatial mixing in trees we can truncate
this self-loading with tree up to the
log and level and run this truncated of
the recursion from arbitrary initial
value this will give us a pretty good
approximation of the marginal
probability so it will also give us F
Peters
okay this construction of self loading
web tree held for all to spin systems
and also for manama dimer model and
generally the hypergraph matchings with
a slightly different for these rules to
dealing to deal with psycho closing
vertices it's it's it's for for general
CSP model so the recursion is for
variables in csps so but still itself
form of tree in the instance graph for
theater CSP also the same same recursion
as in the same model but only energy
unsure got the answer the question is
are the activities uniform from state to
state which is that not man the activity
is what activity do them in there must
the constant station okay that was a
good look my question and you basically
have the same Hamiltonian beef stick
yeah any serious yeah yeah that's what
he's a suit okay okay so so it's
sufficient to prove strong spatial
mixing entries to support at Peter's
right so so let's just consider the haka
model and now our goal is to prove this
translation mixing in trees with spawned
in maximum degree and as with the
assumption of this uniqueness condition
which correspond to the week special
mixing in this particular regular G and
wise approach to this goal is to prove
this I come editorial proposition which
says the extremal case for the week
spatial me
among a family of trees with boundary
that degree it's given by this regular
tree particular regulars this is in
enough to prove the strong spatial
mixing for the hacker model because the
hacker motto is self reducible which
means remember remember that strong
visual mixing is nothing but weak
special mixing with some condition and
for several your supermodel fixing
vertices is if effectively same as you
have a smaller tree so weak special
mixing among in a far family of trees
with bounded degree is the same as
strong spatial mixing for FMF the trees
so now prove this extremal result
observe that irregular tree can be
simulated by a regulatory with
non-uniform external field where the
missing vertices having the zero-field
so this vector of non-uniform fields is
one one corresponding to the e
regulatory ok and let r plus an hour-
sub L be the extremal marginal ratio at
the root in this regulatory achieved by
any boundary condition at level l by the
by the monotonicity of the system we
know that these extremely boundary
conditions must must be all occupied or
unoccupied condition and so there's
quantity follows this recursion and we
can define the same thing for the
regular tree with uniform field also
follow the same recursion and we then
apply a quite delicate induction to this
recursion and we can prove that this gap
is on the gap for the irregular tree is
always dominated by the regular version
so this proved the the week special
mixing the extremal case for the week
special mixing in terms of this log of
ratio as indeed the regular chain oh
yeah the vector of lambda is just a
lambda or zero yeah so of course poly by
yeah so then we have this and also
assuming the week spatial mixing week
spatial mixing for this particular for
this particular regulatory which
corresponds to our uniqueness condition
we have the strong spatial mixing with
same rate and in particular if this
lambda is below this threshold we have
exponential rate decay and I don't know
I really don't know the combinatorial
interpretation of this maybe later in
later slides USC is and also by the by
the psaltery better self within work
tree with such strong spatial mixing you
have a penis under this condition and
also wise approach easily give us the
strong spatial mixing add to the unique
in the threshold but with much slow rate
not enough to support fast air risen and
also an amazing for due to these amazing
results when lambda is greater than this
rascal the problem is in approximate oh
and of course this leaves the one case
open which is our first open problem in
this talk the approximate bility of the
hard core model when lambda right at
this threshold
so you may think this is just a one
meaningless special case and also wise
technique wise approach may be too
delicate to extend to other models but
just consider this model the matching of
hypergraphs of hypergraphs responded a
degree and a bounded edge size and the
duality it's it's equivalent to the
independent sets in hypergraph machines
but there are at least two two
definitions for independent set in
hypergraphs and this correspond to the
less popular one so anyway it's just a
natural CSP problem with variables on
one side poleon verbs on one side and
constraints on the other side and these
constraints are packing constraints or
matching constraints for at least one at
most one constraints so which means it
is satisfied as long as the sum of the
involved where rules is at most one
otherwise it's false ok so this gives us
a natural CSP problem and the partition
function is the sum over the feasible
solutions the weight of the feasible
solutions where the weight is given by
the lambda to the number of swans ok and
the degree on this side is sponded by t
plus 1 and this side is funded by k plus
1
in this model generalized post-hardcore
model and the monomer dimer model when K
equals one this is just the dimer model
when d equals 1 this is a hard core
model and for this model the uniqueness
threshold in the unit for infinite
uniform regular hyper tree is this so
the pecos one is just a uniqueness
threshold for hot rod and width wise
approach we can prove the strong spatial
mixing up to this this threshold with
the same rate as the week's fish mixing
so we have a peters a below this
threshold and due to a very simple
reduction from the hulk remodel by
doubling the hyper edge when lambda is
about twice beyond about twice this
threshold we have hard days but between
them between these two way we know
nothing and this threshold a case now is
quite meaningful because it corresponds
to a combinatorial problem counting the
matchings in three uniform hypergraphs
of maximum degree file for this case
lambda critical is just a 1 so this is
just accounting the numbers so this
natural combinatorial problem sit right
at the threshold so so and suddenly so
this gives us the second open problem to
close this gap and now is there's some
quite some inconsistency between upper
and lower bound for the hardness the
heart instance has many small cycles and
for every side we know from wise
approach the week special mixing the
extremal case for weeks visual mixing as
well as translation mixing just two
trees regular sheets so
inconsistent and we now we we think it
looks like this curve cannot be tight
right but there's also a barrier result
to the current hardness reduction the
local convergence required by the by the
hardness to the infinite regular tree
does not exist for any sequence of
finite hypergraphs FK is not equal 1 so
I'd love to so it means the we need some
new techniques to close this gap either
algorithm without strong spatial mixing
or hardness without local convergence so
it allowed to talk more about this open
problem in our weekly seminar maybe now
let's move on to the next next I will
introduce a powerful tool for the
spatial mixing strong spatial mixing the
potential method we call it a steal for
hardcore model it's enough to protons
the barrier of mixing if we can bound
this ratio at the root the gap of the
ratio at the root with arbitrary pair of
boundary conditions disagreeing at level
l of further and these ratios follow the
recursion follow this recursion so it's
same true to show that for this
dynamical system of the recursion in
this tree with arbitrarily fixed values
in the middle and the final output at
the root is insensitive to this
arbitrary in initial values so let's see
let's first I simplify the situation
that and look at this symmetric version
it is a univariate
it is a univariate dynamical system with
a unique nique fixed point and if this
fixed point is attractive by attractive
i mean the derivative at fixed point has
absolute absolute value at most one and
it's a the fixed point is attractive but
if and only if lambda is a bounded by
this critical threshold so recall this
is the uniqueness condition okay f is
just this recursion Federation the tree
recursion for the region so you have
your cell phone work tree and you have
your recursion for computing the
marginal ratio ok and suppose you know
you know just to start with a simplified
symmetric version right and we know that
if the fixed point is so attractive the
system converged within the local
neighborhood around this fixed point and
otherwise in phase repulsive it's it
does not converge so the uniquely is for
now the uniquely this condition is just
a necessary condition for the for the
convergence of this symmetric system we
want to make this also a sufficient
condition for the convergence of general
multivariate system
and this is done by the potential
analysis translating the recursion
quantity to another quantity called the
potential so we apply this translation
to their current a recursive quantity X
to Y we call it the potential by a
monotone potential function fee we have
done this already because recall that we
first we first have a recursion for the
marginal probability P and now this
recursion is actually for the marginal
ratio R so by doing this we already
translate p to r by this mud at home
mapping from P to R so nothing forbid us
to do it more so we just so it just for
a mysterious reason we just choose to
choose this potential function and with
this potential function we can figure
out the new recursion G of Y and this
new recursion is really nice its
gradient is bounded everywhere assuming
the attractive attractiveness of the
fixed point you can verify this the
derivative of this new recursion is
given by this see see see now we can see
this potential function help us to
modify the the derivative of F and we
choose our by choosing our by choosing
the directive of this potential function
at this so now you get some idea why we
choose this strange potential function
because we want this directive and with
this directive we have a nice balance
the trade-off between X and FX and FX is
a decreasing function so hopefully they
have some trade-off here and indeed this
is always founded by
by the by the you know by are always
founded by some constant lesson one
assuming the assuming the uniqueness
condition so that's this is for the so
so assuming the unique x condition the
the new recursion the new system for the
potentials always contract no matter
where we are at every step so let's for
the univariate system now move on to the
multivariate certain general
multivariable system and we still apply
the same translation here and we can
figure out the new recursion for the
potentials a multivariate recursion and
for any pair of initial values it caused
some arrows everywhere at every vertex
and these arrows are combined due to the
mean value theorem is combined as an
inner product of the gradient between
the gradient and the arrows at the
children and this is the inner product
where the capital three represent a
derivative of the potential function and
we take the maximum we take the maximum
of the arrow among the children and the
factor is now move out like this and by
choosing still by choosing the potential
function at this we have this nice
balanced form and due to the jensen's
inequality it can be funded by the
symmetric version which we know is
always less than one assuming the
uniqueness condition so this gives us a
car this gives us exponential decay
along a worse that werster case past
alone or worse
in the system for the potentials and
assuming of course assuming the
uniqueness condition and then we can
translate this back to the original
system for the marginal ratios or the
marginal probabilities and this we will
give us some overhead console overhead
caused by the first and the last step of
translation let's do its exponential
decay and that's for the hard core model
we can prove the strong spatial mixing
in this way and this technique this
approach can be extended to general
system like the anti ferromagnetic
Verrel to speed model by antiviral I
mean beta times gamma is less than 1 so
the disagreeing neighbors are favored
over a green ones okay and so now the
general recursion is like this for the
general to spin model when beta equals
zero gamma equals y is just a hug or not
oh that's also for the ratios mar
generation and applying this choosing by
choosing this derivative of the
potential function like this so remember
only the directive of potential function
does matter even though its integration
not necessarily have a closed form as
long as it's monotone that's enough and
then the decay factor in the potential
lord is given by this which is still
pretty balanced as a similar form to the
actuary to the turret the derivative and
also it's always sponded below 1 as long
as the uniqueness condition is satisfied
at d plus 1 regular she
so for antiviral crispin model I'm
graphs with pandya the maximum degree we
define the uniqueness condition we
define a unique in this condition as the
regime that week special mixing on all
all d regular trees holds for bundle d
and this gives us a regime for the beta
gamma lambda and when the beta gamma
lambda the parameters in the interior of
this regime we have a Peters graphs
responded degree and if the perimeter is
strictly outside this region the problem
is is hard to approximate and a new
phenomenon in general and referral to
spin model is the decay rate is no
longer in the longer be monotone in the
degree so so the worst case so recall
that a wise approach the key step in
wise approach the extremal case for the
week special mixing on 10 family of
trees may no longer be the regular tree
of the highest degree and this
complication is actually also a blessing
because as the degree grows the decay
rate jobs so fast we can have fast
algorithms for general graphs with
unbounded degrees so all together this
gives a completed classification of the
Proxima bility for feral to spin except
for the critical threshold on all graphs
of bundle degrees and also on all
general graphs
that's the good news for antiviral and
for feral feral to spin where the beta
times gamma is greater than one things
things get much more complicated and due
to these classical algorithms we have
appear at Paris for Pharaoh Ising model
with all uniform external field external
field and also our activities and for
the federal general fairies Pharaoh to
spin within this regime we also have
randomized algorithms and also deer is
also a regime which is a bit hard to
approximate and I'm not going into
detail description about this knowledge
except telling you that there's still a
gap between upper and lower bound and
even just these algorithms detail is the
constant rate crisis in our belief of
the of that the correlation decay
somehow captures a proxima bility of
this model because ferrocene model not
does not always have correlation decay
in all trees yet it still approximately
so the model isn't proximal despite
there's no decay of correlation or maybe
there is maybe there are some sort of
other decay of courage so let's consider
this this weaker form of decay of
relation even weaker than the week
spatial mixing I call this a primitive
spatial mixing the name is is
unofficially it did not it did not exist
the last week but the notion has been
there for a while
so for a family of trees the root of the
trees we say a primitive spatial mixing
holds PSM hold if any pair of rutina
trees which are isomorphic to each other
for the first l levels the marginal
distribution at the respect to roots are
pretty close ok so compared to the week
special mixing it's even even weaker
because it has no fixed vertices so no
boundary condition no vertices have
States fixed and in the dynamical system
it means the old initial values must be
realizable by sub trees and in order to
show how much it this notion of decay of
Croatian is connected to to the parks
and accounting let's deviate a little
bit to the concept of belief propagation
so given a graph possibly with cycles
the loopy belief propagation is just
like this it defined like this we
maintain a variable for every edge
orientation and starting with some
arbitrary initial value we update these
variables according this updating rule
this is not exactly the same as what you
have seen the loopy belief provocation
but they're equivalent so it's basically
it's loopy belief propagation put in our
framework of the tree recursion so at
any time T for any variable we check
back it's a tree right all the way to
the initial value so certainly if we
have weak spatial mixing all trees we
have the convergence for this procedure
but if you choose the initial Y values
wisely you can choose your initial value
it's your air ism and so that every
initial value is realizable by some sub
tree and then primitive special mixing
on trees is enough to guarantee the
convergence for this restricted
restricted procedures it's not an egg
resuming it's a heuristic because even
if it the convergence it does not
guarantee to converge to a correct value
but it gives some idea why this even
weaker notion of decay of Croatian may
support everything and next here
probably is the most controversial part
of the talk here is a conjecture the
approximate e of feral to spin systems
on all graphs is captured by the
primitive spatial mixing on all trees I
don't know how much it is true but seems
that the existing algorithms does do not
refute this conjecture also harding's
and also there's some recent very recent
result making progress towards this
conjecture it proves that in this regime
of the primitive special mixing indeed
house on all trees and in a thorough
ferromagnetic Eugene and if edition beta
is pillow is smaller than one then
fixing vertices for this regime fixing
vertices has the same effect as having a
sub tree down there so PSM is equivalent
to SSM among all trees in this
Jim so we have SSM then we have at
Peter's so recall that for the hardcore
model painting is just pruning just a
delete some vertices so certainly for
hardcore model a model like that or any
self reducible model PSM is among all
trees is it our class of bounded degree
trees as equivalent as the SSM for this
family now that towards this this
conjecture the challenging part is to
show we can have error isms at peter's
or f / us even p sm is strictly weaker
than the week's fisheries so we have
primitive spatial mixing but we do not
have weeks patience and that's exactly
what Jeremy Sinclair's ran work for the
ecig model have done okay and the okay
that's the the Marty spin the cue
coloring and for this problem the we
know the uniqueness threshold on regular
trees and below this traffic you less
than the curious number of your color
and Delta is the degree
the problem is hard to approximate and
from the air is inside the correlation
decay base terrorism failed miserably
for this problem it seems that even
achieving a threshold like Q is twice
the degree is difficult enough
challenging enough and consider that's
only that's almost a starting point have
folded for the randomized algorithm and
if for spatial mixing only result we
have some better bounds by analyzed by
keep checking the arrow propagations in
the original gibbs measures but not in
the some competition device like self or
de mogi so to closing the gap between
upper and lower bound for this problem
is one of the most important important
open problems in the area so I cannot
help listing it here is irresponsibly
and there are several reasons for the
failure of the correlation decayed based
algorithms so we we still have similar
recursions for the marginal
probabilities like this one and for each
neighbor and the color we create a new
instance and so it's a it's a vector to
vector system recursion and and ideally
these vectors are so supposed to be
simplex is ideally they aren't supposed
to be marginal distributions and that's
true in trees if your graph is tree
that's true but in the general graph
it's no longer true because for
different color we actually access to
two different instances they're not they
do not belong to the same marginal
distribution
a complication and that's net seems to
be true for other recursions and also
the recursion has increasing in some
variables and decreasing some others
also a complication and anyway the the
current technique for strong spatial
mixing fails seems you know fails to to
overcome this complication so maybe just
a establish threshold for the strong
spatial mixing is is challenging enough
for this problem oh yeah this this model
so that's all I can talk about about
them the Marchese spin system so let's
move back to the truth spin model for
this model we understand it better
recall that we have a dynamical system
for marginals or four for medina ratios
or four for the potentials translated
from these quantities and the
propagation of arrows the combination of
arrows in this dynamical system is given
by this inner product and here X is just
some values among the children
determined by the mean value theorem so
it's pretty arbitrary and the previous
so yeah that's for the hacker model
that's too abstract concretely for the
hacker model with this choice of
potential function this is our inner
product and the previous approach is to
take this take the maximum over these
arrows and we have ever at one norm of
the gradient outside and this basically
gives us courage indicate along a worst
path and if ideally we have decay not
for the max but for the sum of the
arrows and smut much better
and more generally and practically if
not for l1 norm but el pino of arrows
then every path from the root to the
disagreeing boundary contribute
something to the arrow at top and it
means that the cave or correlation is
determined by the number of self Odom
works to the disagreeing path to the
deer screen boundary it's it's a it's a
refined way to capture the correlation
decay because if ideally if it is in
deal indeed that the K fall for the sum
it's a one not then we can have some
aggregate version of SSM I will be
defined later but anyway it implies the
optimal mixing time for global dynamics
if this the model is monotone I will
also mention later and if it's not for
l1 knowledge it's not so idea is for
some LP known with some finite p then we
can have air ism f peters photographs
with one day to connect constant which
is a notion of average degree not Maxum
degree ok so let's first define this
aggregate version of spatial mixing so
recall that in a gifts measure and we
have a boundary of the region and for
every boundary vertex we take the
extremal influence to the marginal
distribution at vertex V caused by any
pair of boundary conditions that
disagree that differ only at this
boundary vertex ok and enumerate all of
them and sum over all these extremal
influence
if this quantity decane we say we have
aggregate weak or strong spatial means
and the difference between Wiggins run
is still whether we have this extra
condition and certainly it's easy to see
that if you have a SSM you have SSM but
the other way around the other direction
is not necessarily true in general
because I essm is pretty strong it
basically says almost says you you you
you pass can decide the decay of
correlation individually so but for in
general in general a pass along usually
has slowed most much substantially slow
decay of recreation then a pass hidden
in for inner energy but there are few
exception then if you have due to a a
very elegant coupling proof we know if
we have a assm aggregate version of
strong spatial mixing the mixing time of
caliber dynamics is optimal you have
this optimal mixing time and although we
still have a pitas of course we have a
pittance but the correlation decay a
rhythm the deterministic ones although
is polynomial it's a large polynomial
but here if we have the strong version
of spatial mixing we have very fast
randomized save ourselves and the
monitoring system here in the two-speed
model means it's Farrell to spin or anti
Farrell to spin on bipartite graphs so
something we can apply censoring
technique
and back to our inner product if ideally
we can have this sort of decay of
creation for the l1 norm and with this
factor with this factor then we have
aggregate version of strong spatial mix
it's easy to see because the girls rate
of the number of past slower is slower
than the contribution along every path
so accumulation still decaying and this
can be achieved for feral to spin model
with finally degree in this regime and
it's quite easy to prove just to apply
the same analysis with a very natural
potential function log X the log of the
region it's have time for doing this but
you can believe me so in this regime we
have this thing and in l1 not decaying
Eleanor which is assm and which gives us
optimal mixing time and observe that for
the easing model without feel without
external without field means lambda
equals 1 this is just the uniqueness
threshold but in general for other to
spin model it's not it's strictly
stronger than the uniqueness condition
okay and also it's yeah it's a decaying
l1 norm is really strong so we'd only
expect to hold that generally but we can
still maybe relax a little bit to to
have decay in in LP nom right d creating
MP not so practically for every nom we
have a P to the power of p here is
influenced I'm not sure how whether it
will imply the same leur optimal mixing
time that'd be nice
but still with that relaxed decay in LP
Nam we can have a Peter's for graphs
with pundit average degree measured by
the connected constants the connector
constant is extensively study the
quantity in physics and also in
mathematics so in an infinity graph it
is defined as this limit and can be
naturally extended to the family of
finite graphs and basically is just a
set is roughly gives the girls rate
average girls rate of the number of self
loading works from a workings and so it
gives some notion of every degree and
for example for the eris rainy graph a
random graph with every degree constant
every degree t with high probability the
connector constant is very close to the
every degree while its maximum degree is
log n over log log n super constant and
the computation of connected constant
for the infinite lattice graph is
notoriously hard and even for this
particular honeycomb lattice the exact
value of this connect of its connected
constant is considered as bricks ooh in
mathematics now go back to this inner
product this combination of arrows we
apply the holders inequality to break
this in a burger product into lP&L cunin
and if this lq norm of the gradient can
be bounded by some vector alpha then we
basically we can say we have strong
vision mixing and FPS for the family of
graphs
with kinect a constant fungal aided by 1
over alpha because it's easy to see
because the girls rate the girls rate of
of the number of paths is basically
Delta 2l in l level and the contribution
of the decay is are 42 l cancel this we
have installation decay and for the hard
core model back to the hardcore mode
apply the holders inequality with this
very critically to chosen p LP nom with
this very critically chosen p where
delta c is the critical degree actually
the critical branching factor satisfying
this uniqueness threshold for this
lambda then with this particular p nope
smaller no bigger then this factor is
always bounded by 1 over delta critical
so back to the to the problem we
basically says we have a peters for the
family of graphs for hardcore model for
family grow our crops with bundy to
connect constant as long as the
uniqueness condition is satisfied in
terms of kinetic constant instead
instead of maximum degree and also we
have seen that eating without field we
can work with l1 norm so of course we
have this result and extending this the
scheme we can do this similarly for the
monomer dimer but now for any constant
connected any bounded connected constant
finite connect account and due to a
classical result we know we have epiros
for counting matchings for all graphs
for the monument on your model
for randomized algorithms we have we
have randomized the approximation
algorithm for all graphs and the
actually the deterministic correlation
decay base terrorism works for graphs
with any bond a degree and now extending
somehow to the grass with spongy the
average degree so naturally the last
open question is how to do this
deterministically for any graphs and
that's the these are the lovely open
questions open problems today and we
have various kinds of spatial mixing the
decay of correlations here and for the
heart for the hacker models for akamaru
the first three equivalent for the e
sing without filled with last 38 fluent
and in the potting quite an important
question is to how to establish the
correct one and related to to
approximate county
this is pretty amazing before your talk
I would have guessed that the phasing
model on a tree was somewhat trivial but
does it have a like ferromagnetic
ferromagnetic phase transition itching
like some temperature like yeah yeah
yeah it does in infinitive regular tree
right yeah yeah it does uniqueness at
week special mixing its without fuel is
it's just a Miss a ESN assn without feel
the same as this is what's known about
that phase transition do you know like
is it the same your versatility classes
like icing on that square grid oh that's
full lettuce graph it's more complicated
and you know we we kind of yeah we we
can prove the week special mixing
because we can post Ross Fisher mixing
and of course we can prove week special
mixing up to some some some parameter
threshold but it still has as a is a
some gap from the conjecture one for the
greed and for other lattice model graded
here's a impaired clue empirical
threshold for the phase transition it's
like is 3.7 something that currently its
approach the one is two point
holanda for the hardcore model sorry for
using oh yeah for eating with our field
yeah I can solve it but for with few who
knows ya feel we don't even have this we
don't have a conectar con sentencing
what I mentioned here is almost just
everything so for any other models it
doesn't work actually
another model but the belief is somehow
that like looking at trees you can get a
good sense of these sorts of hardness
dichotomy theorems for general graphs
yeah yeah that's my belief but ok ok
yeah